The general good experience.
I was working at a Warner brothers, uh, tiny Toon adventures. And I was, uh,
I was, uh, I was a PA production assistant at that time.
It was the first job I ever had in LA. And a guy says, uh, Hey,
we're going to have a party tonight. We're going to watch these fights.
They're like cockfights, come on over and let's watch them.
And I went over to his house and I was literally hypnotized watching hoist
Gracie, do what he did. I couldn't believe it.
Everybody else was talking the three first day, the very first,
the first UFC. It was the first one. Wow. So you,
you watched the first one live. Yeah,
I saw it at a party that I was not supposed to be at and nobody else was paying
attention to this. It was just on, it was like two other guys watching it.
And uh, and I'm watching this going. I got to do that.
Like it was speaking to me in a way I've never, you know,
like art speaks to me and I was watching it. And,
and the next day I find Torrance Gracie Academy. Cause they kept saying Torrens,
Gracie. And I knew it worked Torrance was so I, I,
I was living in studio city in the Valley. I drove my huddle,
Honda prelude. I drove all the way on the four Oh five,
the worst for you in the world.
It took him about three hours to get down there on a Saturday morning.
And I walked into that place and it was, they were done,
but I could smell all that sweat and humidity and nastiness. And I was like,
Oh God, this is great. And I walked in and, and they were very nice to me,
but there was like these dudes and they look so intimidating and they were just
ripped up and clot up and dripping wet.
And this wasn't the pretty days where everybody has rash guards and designer
Gies. This was like, Croogan's Gies they were yellowed and nasty smelling.
And, and no, there was no, there was chest hair in your mouth.
I remember crew guns. And uh, and,
and they came walking out and I was just like, I felt.
Talk a little bit. I was just looking at it. I want to be you. Okay.
And he goes, where are you from? You know, and I'll go, Oh,
the Valley in the Valley, this is too far my friend. And he goes to my cousins,
John jock is in the Valley. The Machado's go there. And, uh,
I was kind of like struck and all by everything. Right. So I thought, okay,
I'll go to the Valley, you know? And there was no internet, no understanding.
There's no internet. You can't just Google.
So I got the Thomas guide out and I started looking around and,
and I would ask people. And,
and so nobody knew the answer to this because remember, as you know,
in the early days presented you just, Sue was like, Oh,
you do that karate stuff. Yeah. And so I, uh, I got on my mountain bike.
I was a heavy mountain biker then and I got on my bike and I was in studio city
and I decided to ride Ventura Boulevard and I'm gonna look at every shop on
Ventura Boulevard. And I was driving, I got all the way down to Encino and, uh,
and just, and I see this jujitsu, right. And I go, Oh, that's it.
I walk in.
And this little kind of chubby round guy comes walking up and is tucked into his
geek. And he goes, I kind of help you. And I go, I'm looking to do, uh,
I'm looking to do that ground fighting stuff. And he goes, yeah,
we do that here. And I go, okay. Yeah, sign up.
And so I signed up and I'm there a week and I'm there every day.
And not once are we on the ground, we're doing the standup small circle stuff.
And like an I'm looking at my classmates and they're all like horribly out of
shape. And like, they can barely move. And I'm thinking, God,
this isn't what I saw. That was the place. It was like motion Rouge, jujitsu.
Right. But I was so out of my head trying to find it.
And so I'm there a week and he's like, Hey, congratulations, you get a belt.
And I'm like, I hardly know anything.
And so he gives me a spelt and I'm working out this one guy and he says, Hey,
I think what you want is the Machados. And I was like, Ooh, where am I?
This isn't it, dude. I'm looking in the wrong movie. And so I go,
okay. Uh, he goes, that's down the road, dude, like four stores, four shops,
four shops short. Right.
So I literally at class I'm like curling up and I'm like, Oh, I got to go.
I walked down there and I see them. And it was, this is on Ventura Boulevard.
He wasn't at his place in, in Tarzana yet.
He was getting ready to move that week.
And I walk in and it was a place as big as this studio. I'm not kidding.
And he goes, you know, judge, I spoke very poorly English back then.
And he was like, Oh, hello. And I'm like, uh, sign, I sign up now.
You know? And so I signed up and I started going to him,
but I had made like two friends say, I want an Adelaide.
I didn't have any friends who was there to work and become my goal.
And so I was still talking to these guys and still going to the other place and
the time worked out where he was early and I would leave and go next door to
John jock. Right. So I was there, but yeah,
another week and we're just doing drills at Jean-Jacques,
we're doing armbar drills over and over again from our back from open guard
drills. And I would go home and I would draw it in my book.
I had a sketchbook of everything. So everything we learned, I would draw it.
And I would, you know, I was an animator for a long time,
so I could animate the movements and I could see in rolling where we would
end up. So if we start here and I did this, this and this,
I knew we would end up over here in this position. In my mind,
it was easy because I had animated.
So I would see rolling like cartoons and they would just kind of roll into it.
And so it came very, I wasn't a wrestler, but it came pretty natural to me,
to the movements. Right. And so, um, so a week later,
the guy at the motion Ruggie, Etsy place was telling me, Oh,
you got to do this because, and I go, but if you did that,
you'd get stuck in an arm bar because he's having me like choke right. Reach up.
And he goes, no, you can't get the number from there. And I go, I think,
I think you can. And he's like, you're not going to do it. And so I go,
well watch. And he got in my guard and he like,
he did his little chest slap thing, you know, those little like,
and he like stuck his arm out the little chest. Yeah.
You know how that they like get ready to fight. And they're like, you know,
they do the poses
in my guard and it was weird and everybody's watching. Right.
And they're standing there watching the instructor, tell me,
I didn't know what I was doing. And he did that. And he,
his arm out and I grabbed his arm and I pulled it in and I threw my legs over
his face and.
I remembered him and he got.
Real off. He goes, he got up and he was really perturbed. And he goes,
that wouldn't work in real time.
That only worked because I was letting you get there. And I,
and I was scared and I go, I think it would work, man.
Think it would work. And remember, I had two friends now, right.
My two guy friends. Right. And they were going and I hear one of them go, Oh,
no, it worked. And I'm looking over at him and he's getting kind of, man.
He's a short guy, but he's real stock. And he goes, uh, he goes, look,
I'm tired of hearing about this Brazilian jujitsu.
So I tell you what you use your jujitsu, which by the way,
I had had like two weeks of training. Now, granted, I was there every day,
which on jock, like doing drills. So, you know,
if you got one movement that you do a hundred times,
you're going to have an inkling of how to do it. What year is this bro?
So you're talking about 94 right after the first year of see maybe like 93,
two months after the first year of six 93, 93. And so head of the curve.
So I'm sitting there and I go, okay. Uh, I think, uh, I think it'll work, dude.
Now I don't know anything about standing. Right? Right.
So he gets up and he goes, okay, I'm gonna attack you. And you attack me.
And I'm like, I don't know how to attack.
He goes.
He goes ready. And like all of a sudden,
I'm in a video game and I'm standing there. So what do I do? I copy what I saw,
always Gracie. Do I stick my arms up? Like the karate kid.
And I stick my foot in front and he starts like,
like coming at me with his elbows and swinging.
And he looks like a little machine and I just took my foot and kicked him in the
front leg. His leg goes down. He lands on me. We fall under the guard.
He starts hitting me with his elbow and the top of the head. Right.
Like I grabbed him, I clenched him. I squeezed him really tight, mostly.
So I didn't get punched in the face. Cause I was afraid.
And I picked my head in his chest and he's hitting me on the top of the head.
And I'm like,
and that heat comes up your back from your to your neck and you go here, you
hitting me now. And I go, okay. All right. All right.
Now we're in a new league now. You're not my friend. Now you're fighting me.
And I literally just kind of monkey shimmied up his high guard.
And I just threw him in an arm bar and I cranked as hard as I could on that arm.
And he screams, Oh wow. And I get up. Right.
And I'm like, you got that blood rush. I'm like, my hair messed up.
Okay.
And I grabbed my bag. I grabbed my bag, my little goofy bag.
I grabbed it and I walk out. Right. I'm like, I don't know what to do.
I'm like flustered.
I walk out and mature dudes come running out after me. They're like, bro, bro,
I'm coming with you. Where are you going? Where's that school at?
And they came and they trained all the way to purple belt.
Both those guys who are the guys that was Jim Lohan, the,
the wood carpenter guy and a guy named Seth.
I don't even remember his last name.
They both trained all the way through purple before they kind of faded away.
And uh, and had you fade away.
When you're at purple, that's such a shame. You're so close.
As an instructor.
Now it crushes me when I give a blue belt to someone and then I see them fade
and I'm thinking, God, dude, you got past the hardest color. Yeah.
The greatest belt you can get is blue.
I say that it's to this day and I'm fourth black blue, because you're a color.
You're not the white anymore. You're in the club.
You're in to the day.
John jock gave me a blue belt was like one of the greatest days of my life.
The day John document, my purple belt. I was like, Oh my God,
I'm close from so close to Brown. Purple is a danger,
but purple volts tap people.
So I remember seeing a lot of purple belts that could tap Brown belts probably
were dangerous. Headlights one really good move. Oh yeah.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.